here this month the president of the New
America Foundation and Marie slaughter
talked about her new book unfinished
business women men work family at the
Washington ideas forum hosted by the
Atlantic and the Aspen Institute the
annual forum brings together political
leaders administration officials
business entrepreneurs journalists and
science and technology experts this is
about 20 minutes
[Music]
hello everybody well Emery we just
introduced you as CEO of New America
Foundation which is true but I suspect
many people know you for a different
accomplishment this little article that
you wrote three years ago which
electrified the country I think is no
overstatement to say the headline was
why women can't have it all
still still can't have it all it was the
cover story of the Atlantic the summer
of 2012 overnight became the most read
story in the history of the magazine and
within two weeks she'd signed a contract
to turn it into a book which is out this
week unfinished business women man work
and family congratulations thank you
so can we assume that in the three years
between 2012 and now you've figured it
out we can all have it all all the data
you're here to tell us how yeah
absolutely
read this book your life will be
transformed forever you know I think the
thing to start with is that I could not
have written this book three years ago
I absolutely could not have written it
because I didn't believe what I now am
arguing I mean it really was you know we
overused the idea of a journey but it
was a process of giving lots of speeches
listening to people who wrote to me
engaging with people talking to my own
family you know I found out things about
the way why my father had raised me at
in a very progressive way in Virginia in
the 1960s and it was because he'd
represented women who'd been abandoned
by their husbands and didn't have
anything to live on and he without his
daughter would actually you know have be
able to make a living deport yourself
absolutely and looking at my mother's
work and her work as an artist and her
work as a as a really nurture of our
family and then talking to my own
husband and one of the great paradoxes
of this whole thing is I did go home
from the State Department to be with my
children after two years when this
article came out I was in more demand
than ever
and actually gone more not as gone as
much as I'd been in the State Department
but definitely on the road and my
husband really family that way from my
family and my it was a great irony you
know they would tease me oh great you
know go go out there give a speech so
this is obviously a very personal
journey it is walk us back to that
moment you were in this high-powered job
at the State Department you're commuting
your families back in Princeton New
Jersey you were here during the week was
there was there a particular moment
where you suddenly went uh-huh this
ain't working
something's got to give uh well I would
say in for two years I had been in this
constant tug of war where I loved the
work and this is what I wanted to do and
I would get these phone calls and my son
was just you know being a teenager and a
particularly acute case of teenage hood
and I would be saying you know what am I
doing here and I would say that to my
assistant like why am I here so that was
not new what was really the moment was
and I described this that when secretary
Clinton's chief of staff essentially
asked do you want to put your name in
for only there only a couple of jobs
above mine and they were supposed to go
they were all good and at that moment it
was I could stay
I could go up maybe maybe Andy and the
boys could come to Washington but I knew
that wasn't gonna work and that was the
moment where I said no you know I really
do have to go home and two years later I
didn't put my name back in which was
equally a surprise because at that point
I decided I had I wanted to be home well
here's my confession in anticipation of
interviewing you today
your publisher kindly couriered the book
to me at my hotel in New York where I
was on a work trip this week and I tried
to start it on the train home but my
youngest son's soccer carpool was
falling apart I had to sort that out
from the quiet car and then I was trying
to read it in between meetings and
interviews and my other son got injured
and we had to get the pediatrician on
the line and it's long story short I
ended up racing through the final
chapter in the taxi in the taxi which
prompts a number of questions one of
which is are the people who would
benefit from your book to frazzle to
have
time to read it so that is such a great
question somebody wrote me when I wrote
the original article and said you are
clearly not a working mother because if
you were you would know no one can read
13,000 words you know I I I think that's
definitely an issue it's I think very
readable you can read it in in in chunks
you know the but the biggest change from
that article in this book this book is
not just written for working women
indeed this book says as long as we keep
thinking of this as a working women's
issue we are not going to fix it we have
been doing that for 20 years it's so I
actually try to change the frame right
to widen it and to say this is actually
a care problem it is a problem of
workplaces not making room for care and
that you know it's it's as if well women
went into the workforce 60% of American
women 70 over 70% of American mothers
are in the workforce and the workforce
still assumes that all of us women and
men have somebody at home so when the
car pool doesn't work and there's an
entry and my favorite is always when
your kid says oh yeah I have this
project it was assigned three weeks ago
it's due tomorrow no I don't have any of
the materials you know it's that kind of
thing that this is really about making
room for what is a fact for all of us
and the second part of the book says not
just women but men and that unless we
think of men as working fathers in the
same way we think of women as working
mothers where we're all both we're not
gonna make the changes we need to make
let me pick up because in that answer
you just used the term working father
yes not something you hear as much as
working mother although I think could
just use that as well
and one of the things you stress over
and over in the book is it matters how
we talk about this stuff it may be
semantics but that matters I was struck
I got waylaid by the coffee yesterday I
was on stage doing different interviews
a man in the audience who noticed I was
going to be interviewing you about this
today grabbed me and said you know what
I love that she doesn't this she uses
the term lead parent yes and that's so
much more empowering than stay-at-home
mom stay-at-home dad
semantics but but it matters but it does
matter and I actually I'm old enough to
remember when we went from miss and mrs.
to miss and I remember everybody thought
this was terrible I lived in the south
and we'd been saying news forever but
still different meaning different
meaning and you know people thought it
was silly but of course it wasn't silly
because miss and missus told everybody
that what mattered most about a woman
was her marital status and nobody had
nobody could tell whether a man was
married or not and similarly absolutely
the fact that we always say working
mother and what we say about that is
we're still assuming a mother's job is
to be caring for our children so if
she's working you need an adjective but
we never say working father when in fact
if you described all the men out there
all the men in this audience who have
children as working fathers you'd be
saying his job is to raise those
children and not just to provide an
income it's to raise them through care
the other the other one I hate the idea
to never ever say that a man is
babysitting his children yeah I mean
let's let's kill that and this one I
think is a little less intuitive we've
got to banish the word he's helping at
home right helping is not actually
taking the burden off you you are still
figuring out what needs to be done and
you aren't asking him to help he is not
the agent right he's the assistant and
if we're gonna get to where we need to
go men do have to be lead parents or
fully equal Co parents and that means
and this was hard for me and II said I'm
happy to do this or I want to support
you I'm gonna do this but I'm not doing
it your way right I'm doing it my way
and I don't care if you don't like how I
fix up the kitchen and I don't care if
you think that I'm not I'm disciplining
the boys they're in the way a different
way than you do you want to do it your
way you come home and that's something I
think a lot of us as women action
kind of secretly think we really do know
better at home and so we really do need
to direct them and that's sexism just as
much as a man in the office thinking he
knows better and he's gonna tell you so
that's a big change in my house we
summarized this is the milk challenge in
that sense that my husband says I'm
always happy to stop on the way home
from work if we're out of milk and you
tell me we need it I think yeah they
will never notice that we're out of milk
that but is being the lead parent at
home
well would you let him know be complete
would you let him like decide what to I
think we'd all end up drinking orange
juice all right well I know people want
to get here some of your advice for how
you know and your three years of
pondering that's what you've come up
with one of the strategies that you
advocate is interval training yeah
explain so you know we think about our
careers again sort of 1950s you you get
in into the workforce you go up as fast
as you can pretty much and then at some
point it's over and you may go laterally
and then down
I suggest like athletes we think about
interval training where it took for an
athlete to be in peak performance they
go really hard and then they slow down
and they go really hard again and
actually young people are gonna have
many many different jobs that change is
already happening and they ought to plan
for their career to think about
all right there's this period where I
you know I don't have kids I'm not
taking care of my own parents I can
travel around the world I can work those
crazy jobs that do require you to be on
all the time and then there's these
periods where you know in my case after
I got tenure I spent five years trying
to have kids I was still working but
work was not my primary focus then I
became a Dean and I went really hard
then I slowed down again went into
government slowed down on Ram
they'll offer at same concept well yes
except so part of it does assume you
keep your hand in right and it is and
one of the great things about the
on-demand economy at the high end is
that you can still work on a project
basis doctors coders lawyers engineers
there ways to do this now on a project
basis and so it's more not
rampe so much is ramping up and ramping
down and deciding you know we were
talking before and you were saying your
kids are now at the same school that's a
wonderful thing that gives you time to
go harder or you trade off with your
husband right so if you know that your
husband can be lead parent for a while
and then you know you can trade off your
boss at the State Department it was
Hillary Clinton whose latest trove of
emails came out yesterday your name pops
up a number of times I want to ask you
about one email that's been made public
from Christmas 2009 I think Christmas
2009 and you wrote basically begging
Hillary Clinton to take a day off do you
remember this no I do the other email
says please leave on the 21st so that
those of us who are necessary to make
Christmas happen and here I will say
with all deference to my lead parent
husband there for a long time he
believed in Santa Claus because the tree
magically happened and he would say to
me the first month week and said
December you seem really stressed that I
so I was essentially saying to her look
for those of us who makes the holidays
and you know Christian or Jewish or any
other holidays if you leave we will feel
free to go home if you stay till the
23rd or 24th everybody's gonna feel like
they have to stay and I was basically
saying in my house my children are not
gonna have much of a Christmas and but I
knew she cared about that that's the
piece that doesn't come out I wasn't
writing just out of the blue I knew
Hillary Clinton cared I'd talked to her
about you know having kids and juggling
this when she hired me and Cheryl Mills
had twins at home so with another team
absolutely and then she did that's the
other thing you can't see in the email
but she did actually leave on the 21st
and I did go home and I think every she
was very very sick no diplomacy was
conducted for a few days and somehow we
all
what's so fascinating about that is
you're upfront and gracious and
acknowledging in the book and in the
article that you're writing from a
privileged position that for many many
people it's not about having at all it's
about having enough to just barely make
ends meet but it's it's fascinating to
be reminded that you can be Hillary
Clinton you can be one of the most
powerful people in the world with more
staffers than you can come up with
things to have them do and and she's
still struggling with the whole work
like that the way that the way that we
all do you know if you worked for her
you knew that she cared and I give the
anecdote in the book of Jim Steinberg
who was Deputy Secretary of State and
there's this one week where he just
isn't making the early morning meeting
and his assistant is showing up and by
day four Secretary Clinton was little
bit irritated you know that's the Deputy
Secretary of State and so she sort of
says with just a touch of asperity you
know so where's Jim and his assistants
said well you know his wife is traveling
this week so this is his week he's on
he's taking that his daughters to school
and he'll be back and of course her
reaction was why didn't you tell me he
went up in her estimation at that moment
right and so we knew that there was a
ready willingness to accommodate to the
extent you could it's one thing I guess
if you're the number two guy at state
though and it's another thing if you're
you know the janitor trying to get that
out for a day or the secretary is
backing everybody and one of your
messages is reading from the top end
well but this is also where I really do
think focusing on care changes the
conversation because focusing on
advancing women and again I I want women
in the top of every profession but when
we think about it that way we start
counting because that's the way you
measure how well women are doing so we
count how many women are in the Fortune
500 and we count how many women are in
senior management and how many women
computer scientists all of that does
focus pretty much on wealthy white women
by and large it does not focus on the
millions of women at the bottom because
one of the things I realize is we have
too few women at the top
and too many women at the bottom and
care or our lack of support for care
plays a role at both ends at the top end
it means if you take time out for care
your career goes off track but for the
millions of women at the bottom not
supporting their care means if they take
a day off they can lose a job right and
so focusing on care says we have to put
in place the policies that rich women
can buy their way out of often we have
to put in leave fam paid family leave
paternity maternity and paternity leave
and quality affordable childcare it I'm
sure is not lost on the audience that we
are to women appear having this
conversation and I want to close by by
another confession I guess which is when
I was asked to do this interview I
looked at it because I knew I would want
to read your book and delighted to get
the chance to talk to you but there was
a tiny part of me thinking should give
this to a man which speaks to early
earlier point about having men in this
conversation how many of the book
interviews have you done that have been
with meal a couple I've done a couple we
read Zakaria has both Andy and me know
this weekend and Tom Ashbrook I've done
a couple and I'm getting lots of
responses from men interesting yesterday
I did a radio show where a lot of men
called in and talked about how they're
just as competent at home and they don't
like the assumption that they're not I I
do think that this conversation is ready
to be broken open by men and part of it
is men are missing out right one of the
things my husband said he wrote this
article in the Atlantic why I put my
wife's career first and he says it was
hard on his career it was better for his
marriage it was better for our sons and
it was better for him that he has a
relationship with them that his father
never had with him that he feel he has
grounded it's sort of the anchor of our
family in a way that I think women
that's part of what we get out of being
mothers and also being for
professionals so why shouldn't men have
the equal ability to really enjoy what
fatherhood's about or to be with your
own parents as they are at toward the
end of their lives it's not a burden
when it works it's the greatest thing in
the world we just need to make it work
for everybody an empowering message
Amory slaughter
thank you thank you so much on our road
to the White House coverage this evening
will take